today I have both incredibly tremendous
numbers for Donald Trump coming up in a
sort of different context but also
devastating numbers for Donald Trump so
we're a year out from the election
yesterday we talked about how more than
likely this is going to be an election
like most elections that comes down to
the results in some key battleground
states we looked yesterday at how Donald
Trump is faring in particular States in
head-to-head matchups against the three
frontrunners in the Democratic primary
Joe Biden Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders fine Trump is doing quite poorly
in these battleground states against
Biden and Bernie and he's actually doing
pretty well in those battleground states
against Elizabeth Warren however let's
at least briefly look at the national
numbers because if the national numbers
are even close to accurate we could be
heading towards a historic election
defeat for Donald Trump so let's take a
look Joe Biden in a hypothetical matchup
is leading Donald Trump nationally by 17
according to a new Washington Post poll
Elizabeth Warren is leading Trump by 15
and Bernie Sanders right in there
leading Trump at 14 now these are truly
stunning numbers and of course we've not
seen a popular vote victory in a
presidential campaign by 14 15 or 17 for
a very very long time offhand I don't
remember when the last time was
according to the same poll even mayor
Pete Budaj
and Kamala Harris are leading Trump but
not by as much so let's go through it
piece by piece as I said yesterday do I
expect Donald Trump to lose the popular
vote in 2020 by 14 points by 15 points
by 17 points I don't expect that I
believe some people who today say they
would vote for a Democrat will end up
voting for Donald Trump either out of
fear or due to propaganda or incumbency
bias I believe that it is going to
tighten and indeed a lot of that
lopsided popular vote is going to end up
coming out of big blue states like
California as we saw in 2016 if you look
at polling today in states that are
expected to be the difference makers we
already looked at those numbers
yesterday
it is much tighter you're looking at
four to six you know even a much much
narrower margins but still if the
popular vote is even half as lopsided as
this polling suggests we could have an
unprecedented unprecedented defeat for
Donald Trump in November of 2020 but
Donald Trump could also get himself
reelected even losing the popular vote
by three four even five or six points
there are models where Trump loses the
popular vote by five points but still
wins the electoral college although as
you get to 567 it starts to become more
and more unlikely that you could lose
the popular vote by so much and still
managed to win the electoral college but
these are not numbers that anyone who is
on our side should be counting on or
seeing as a signal that we should relax
and not worry about the outcome because
remember the letdown that was 2016 every
single person should be voting no matter
where you vote now one good sign for the
anti-trump movement is that if you look
at the internals of how this big rift
between Trump and the Democratic
frontrunner has opened up of course
Democrats overwhelmingly voting against
Trump of course Republicans
overwhelmingly voting for Trump but
independents have been slowly shifting
away from Donald Trump and that's a good
sign for the anti-trump movement
Republicans mostly love the guy
Democrats mostly hate the guy and it's
going to be a turnout game but
independent voters shifting to be more
and more against Trump is a bad sign for
him and a good sign for Democrats lastly
we really need to not underestimate that
even if these numbers remain this way
for the next year even if we get out the
vote there can be another 11th hour
Comey letter or you know some equivalent
to it obviously it's not going to be
Comey in 2020 but some equivalent to it
the effect of strategic algorithmic
online advertising could be a difference
maker the voter suppression tactics that
are employed by Republicans at the state
level so the real risk here is
overconfidence which
put Donald Trump in office for another
four years and what we need to do in
order to sort of fight back or overwhelm
those factors that at the last minute
could help Donald Trump is turnout on
our side needs to be so high that none
of those things end up making a
difference so register to vote help
other people register to vote remind
people to register to vote confirm that
you are registered to vote if you
believe that you are report any
registration irregularities or voter
purges to both the media and your local
election officials now not October 29th
not on election day or the day before
we've got to get on this now and if all
of these things come together then we
may be able to remove Donald Trump and
you know 17 points down in a poll to Joe
Biden who cares we don't need to win by
17 it doesn't matter if we can trust
those polls we just need to win and that
is what the focus needs to be for the
next I guess it's like 359 days or
something like that the countdown is
very much on